[Music]
before we even get into it I gotta ask
you a little a little birdie on the
street told me that you're you're
working with Will Smith on his book
right it literally is a birdie on the
street yes his house is like yeah it's
funny cuz he literally lives around the
corner from here you know what I've
never I've never met him I've actually
and I've never really seen him I've seen
him driving his car but I've actually
never he's never interacted with him
he's never that it's crazy he's got this
like incredible 400 acre property yeah
something
it's like Neverland Ranch down there oh
yeah entire compound with multiple
dwellings and like a lake and a full
court basketball court they've got about
a dozen people living there right and uh
you know family and childhood friends
and stuff and he's never there he's
always on the road he does some
Instagram stories from there every once
in a while ya know so I know he's there
from time to time so you're you're
working on a book with him yeah yeah so
is it like a memoir like a self-help
what is the what's the angle a little
bit of both um it's I would say it's a
self-help book told through the lens of
his life uh-huh he just turned 50 he's
he's gone through some midlife crisis
type stuff the last five years or so his
father passed away and kids have grown
up so he's kind of in a stage of his
life where he wants to start giving back
you start opening opening up the kimono
and being like hey this is who I am this
is what my life is really about and this
is what I've learned so it's just for me
it's like it's gotta be crazy it's the
coolest project so charismatic yeah what
is it like when you're just chilling
with him like what is it about him that
makes him so uniquely him he's exactly
the same it's funny cuz all you know
when I when I come home all my friends
like oh man what's he like I'm like dude
he's he's The Fresh Prince so long he is
the Fresh Prince like that is just
that's not acting like that is who he is
you know it's just fun jubilant
we the my sense is that he's one of
those guys that that has that thing you
know Bill Clinton has it there are
certain very charismatic people that
have it that know how to make everybody
feel special right absolutely
what is that quality I don't know you
know it was interesting when I met him
so it's funny because celebrity books in
the publishing world this surprises
people would and the publishing world
celebrity books actually have a very bad
reputation because every celebrity wants
one but none of them actually want to
put in the 18 months of work right to
write it they just want some ghostwriter
to roll in and yeah do it for him they
just want to put it on the shelf and and
they cost a lot of money so they the
books tend to be bad and the publishers
pay they usually lose a bunch of money
on it
so when I went into it you know
everybody kind of told me they're like
hey you know don't just do this cuz he's
who he is and I had a lot of stuff going
on in my career too so I was like
alright I you know I there needs to be a
good book here
I can't I'm not just gonna sign on cuz
uh-huh I like men in black or whatever
so I met him and one of the first
questions I asked myself is is you know
what what is truly unique about him like
what is different about him like what
what is something that he could share
with the world that most people can and
I ended up telling him this the the
first time I I met with him is I said
like you know you're clearly smart
you're very successful you're famous
obviously but you know they're those
things are all pretty common what I told
them is I said spending the three days
with you your emotional intelligence is
off the charts like absolutely off the
charts both in terms of that charisma
that you were just talking about his
ability to just intuitively read and
recognize how people are feeling and
then you know get them feeling good in a
very quick and efficient way
but also just things he's gone through
in his life like just
a lot of hardship and trauma and stuff
that he bounced back harder and faster
than pretty much anybody I've ever met
huh from stuff that happened to him and
I told him I said that's one in a
million you know and I think that's what
that's what the book should be yeah it's
interesting to watch over the last year
how he has embraced social media yeah
come like this crazy you know wizard
[Laughter]
self-improvement and motivation you know
like you see certain Big Time
personalities dabble in it but he just
went he would hold on he well he went
full on
I know his trainer a little bit and his
trainer was telling me that the the idea
really is to shift your thinking like
instead of I'm a movie star who does
social media to just say like I'm a
social media person who occasionally
does movies yeah and he really kind of
embodied that ethos and then just
exploded its Cathy the funny thing about
him too is is he's the own you know
everybody rags on social media these
days everybody can tripes about it he's
the only person who is like like what's
everybody talking about social media is
great and I thought like yeah well cuz
everybody watches you like yeah you you
have no FOMO cuz you're doing the
coolest [ __ ] on social media so he's
just putting out a positive he's
listening masses he's having a button I
think you know he spent so much of his
career hiding himself because that's
what you did when you were a celebrity
in the 90s like you didn't want them
know you want a little mystery him well
in the paparazzi's follow around and
tabloids are publishing stuff about you
all the time and so he spent so much of
his adult life hiding himself from the
world and it's I think he feels like now
he's like oh I get to finally show
people like what I'm about yeah that's
cool have you interacted with Jayden at
all yeah yeah fast yeah Jayden he is
he's the sweet one of the most
impressive young people that I've ever
met like I've known him for a very long
time he's friends with my sons and he
used to come over here and Joe yeah so I
I've known him for years
and you know you see him at the grocery
store right like he's out about and when
every time that I interact with that kid
he is 100% presence oh yeah he looks you
right in the eye he's incredibly polite
and gracious and interested like and
he's out in the world like doing
incredible things yet no one else is
doing
yeah and he's he's genuinely kind I mean
that that was another thing I hate to
say it kind of surprised me like you go
in you're like alright celebrity kids
like you expect him the beat and they
and like they got a lot of wacky press
like mr. for being a little nutty but
what my experience with them is nothing
short of like you know I always leave
feeling good yeah my interaction I'm all
three of his kids I'm hugely impressed
by them very smart very kind very good
young people and it's and yeah they've
got their quirks and you know mistakes
and stuff that they've done in the put
it like I look at it I'm like man if I
grew up like that yeah I wouldn't turn
out that way 99 times out of a hundred
it's some dilettante you know but isn't
motivated to do anything which is kind
of you know the part of the thesis of
your latest book is actually yeah right
so let's set the stage a little bit I'm
sure right you write this first book the
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] and it
just becomes this you know like
unbelievable phenomenon when you sew
like eight mil eight million copies yeah
I think is something like that like I
can't even comprehend the head I can't
you know so like let's let's walk
through I wanna I want to like inch up
to the kind of existential crisis that
you faced and sure and aftermath of this
better you know prior to this you're
like this blogger you're kind of a
4-hour workweek you know experiment in
motion you're up you're putting out
stuff into the world and you write some
blog posts that explode and that leads
to this book yeah but my sense or my
understanding is that you're somebody
who just prided yourself on putting out
good writing and kind of incrementally
gradually organically growing your
audience yes
then you stumble into you know this
phenomenon that nobody could have ever
predicted so elaborate you know it I
always feel weird telling this story
because it you know the last thing
anybody wants to hear is you know boohoo
yeah I know best-selling author but it
it really mess with me because I I guess
since I started writing seriously in my
mid-20s
my dream was I won't have a you know I
want to have a book deal I want to have
a best-seller I want to be on The Times
list I want to like tour the country you
know it was kind of this checklist of
life goals in my head and in my mind it
was like okay I'm gonna like this is
what I'm gonna work towards over my
adult like this is my life's work
this is what I'm gonna be working on
until I'm like 60 and subtle art just
knocked all those out in like two months
right
and so it's which is amazing but on the
other hand it was when he was an
instantaneous thing when it happened I
don't I don't remember at the time it
took a few months to take off uh-huh
it had a decent launch it debuted on The
Times list but then it fell off and then
about three months later it came back
what what do you attribute that to like
it's something specific happen I think I
think it took that long for word of
mouth yeah around swell yeah it took a
minute and then and then it was right
around that time to the the holidays
were kicking in so and it's it does
great on the holidays people it's a good
gift book so it just it started this
ascent and the whole time I'm like
watching it I'm like well this is crazy
this is crazy but every every month I'm
like okay well this is gonna end soon
you know this is my little 15 minutes
enjoy it and now we're about three years
in and it's it's still number one this
week it's been number one in like
14 different countries uh-huh I think
I've had I have number number one and
number two right now in like four
different countries right I mean it's a
silly it is it's reached a point where
I'm like I tell people I'm like you know
I'm I'll take credit for the first
million
you know I worked my ass off for ten
years I I came up with a great title
wrote a great book like I'll take credit
for the first million you know the other
seven or eight like I don't know we're
right on well it's it's it's a book that
I mean first of all the covers bright
orange canvases and you know the title
is gonna grab anybody it has a kind of
pop culture you know aesthetic about it
and and I will freely admit that when
you know it came online and I first saw
it I was like this [ __ ] guy right and
and the truth is is that you're this
ardent well-read student of literature
and history and philosophy and when you
start to read the book it tells a very
different story from you know the my
knee-jerk sense when you look at the
cover and it's funny because I'm I would
imagine that your people are always
saying to you like you know it's easy to
just think oh this is a book about like
you know how to be an [ __ ] basically
yeah right but it's really a book about
trying to help people drill down on what
their values are sure they can be
discerning about what they care about
and yeah I think I think one thing that
I learned over the years of blogging is
that difficult first of all any sort of
self-improvement by its very nature is
going going to be difficult like no
self-improvement feels great you know
it's like if it feels great you're
probably not actually changing very much
like like people on Instagram who are
posting quotes that just make you feel
good about what you're are yeah it's
like oh my god life changing hashtag
life changing and you know three days
later they're doing the same [ __ ] you
know any any real change is by
definition painful stressful difficult
and so if you're gonna write very
honestly about those subjects one thing
I discovered while I was blogging is you
kind of have to like mix a little bit of
honey into the medicine and so that's
that's where like the humor started kind
of the irreverent attitude some of the
stories started to come out because I
just noticed that if you're dropping
f-bombs and you're telling some crazy
story about this time you got drunk in
college then having that difficult
conversation about life purpose or
whatever it may be
after that mm-hmm it goes down much
better for people like if people are
more open to it
yeah whereas if you just launch straight
into like what are you doing with your
life like you know why do you hate
yourself either
nobody wants well you have to be able to
create an emotional connection yeah
right and this is like philosophy for
Millennials I feel like it's written for
that audience very you know
intentionally but you know if you can
tell that story and whoever's reading it
goes I see myself in that now in when
you deliver the medicine they're in a
place to be able to like receive it
exactly exactly and I think that same
shock value that causes a lot of people
to write me off I've actually I've
written about it on my blog like I argue
that there is value to that that that it
is if you can shock people a little bit
they lower their defenses and they're
willing they're more willing to maybe
hear something hear an idea or a
suggestion that they're not they
wouldn't normally be open to so there's
there's definitely there's a method to
the madness and it was very much crafted
over many many years writing online it's
one of those things where in the
publishing world I'm like this star new
author and I'm like dude I've been doing
this yeah twelve years overnight success
yeah right but it had to be completely
disorienting well yes when this happened
yeah I mean it's it sounds crazy but I
woke up and I'm like I don't know what
to do you know it's like okay yeah I got
that checklist in my head of what I was
gonna be working on till I was 60
everything was checked off so I'm like
alright and then then you got money
pouring in I'm like alright I guess I
don't know here you are you've done
everything that you ever aspired to do
and you're as successful as you could
have ever possibly imagined being and
you have the means to make choices about
your life like you're basically sitting
in this position that everybody you know
works so hard to get to right yeah and
you know let's let's you know paint the
picture of the truth of what it's like
to actually achieve your dream
yeah it's immune it's I mean there's
pride for what you've created absolutely
there's a lot of pride and there's a lot
of gratitude but there's also I mean
it's like getting slammed into a midlife
crisis at 60 miles an hour because I'm
through what you just said it's true I
did I hit everything I ever aspired to
do and I was 32
so I'm like crap I still have like to do
something for the next 50 years and and
figuring out what that next thing to do
with your life is is difficult and and
then on top of that I guess just that
the nature I guess of having a
successful creative career is the
incentives don't line up exact same
executive at a company you get paid for
being there like you you your pay is
proportional to how much you show how
often you show up and how much value you
add to that company when you're a writer
I mean I I was sitting around 2017 I'm
like well I could go back on tour and
promote the book for a month or I could
just sit around play Zelda and I'm gonna
sell the exact same amount of coffee so
I'm just gonna sit around and play video
games and and that's fun for a month or
two but it eventually this kind of did
you make a bunch of crazy purchases no
that's the other thing I'm a really
Spartan dude mm-hmm the honest-to-god
truth my big purchase was I bought a
Nintendo switch yeah
I gotta like traveled the world you
probably had already been traveling and
I've already jet I've already done that
um I took the wife to Paris you know we
did a bunch of like fancy restaurants
and stuff and and we did a nice birthday
tray so I mean there was some there were
some little things there but I mean I
was already living the life I wanted
so iid I quite honestly didn't know what
to do with myself and so it the end
result was this very strange situation
because I kind of went through this lost
depressed period in my early 20s of like
I have no idea what to do I'm broke I
like have no I have no opportunities in
front of me like I that that whole loss
of purpose you know that that a lot of
people experience like I went through
that and Here I am on the complete
opposite situation I've achieved
everything I wanted yeah a buttload of
money tons of opportunities but I feel
exactly the same like I've got this
weird depression going on but you're
well-read enough to know to to to have
like predicted that right like we're all
told look you know money's great but
it's it's not gonna change you know it's
not gonna it's not gonna make you happy
like all these platitudes about success
and Danny yeah but then when you
experienced it was it was your your
experience surprising to you or
different than what you might have
imagined I think what surprised me is
that it felt exactly the same as it did
when I had nothing
uh-huh I thought it was gonna feel you
know I knew would be weird and
disorienting but I thought it would feel
different and in and I should note that
it's like I see now why people
self-destruct when they experience
success that quickly 22 bring will back
into it I talked to him about this and
he said that uh he said Quincy Jones
used to call it altitude sickness
he said if people right if people
experience success too quickly mm-hmm
they get sick and pass out yeah
and fall down the mountain right and I
get it it's crazy how did will avoid
that I mean he was pretty young
yeah I think for will it happened first
of all who's 17 so I don't think he ever
and he started rapping when he was like
13 so I don't think he ever everything
was always on this kind of trajectory
but I think it happened to him I say
gradually but you know I actually I
think he went through a period he got
famous and rich and then blew it all and
so he had that valley
oh he did for a couple years yeah in the
late 80s yeah he owed the IRS like 1.6
million or something like he made like 6
million bucks when he was 18 and then
blew through all of it and then his next
album flopped and so he had this this
like two year period before the Fresh
Prince show yeah that he was like in a
pretty dark spot and so I think he went
through that in a very like more extreme
right so you're what 32 when this
happens yeah you're on the couch and at
some point you have to just realize like
hey I'm a writer and this is what I do
right right divorce yourself from this
you know attachment or idea that like
have peaked yeah never be this good
again yeah and try to fall in love with
what it was that got you you know
started in the first place
you'd be the other interesting thing
about success like that is that there it
introduces all sorts of new pressures
you know so now the publisher wants
right
you know the publisher wanted subtle art
not giving a [ __ ] for dreams and let's
just let's just you know note that now
there's this just proliferation of books
that have covers that look very similar
to this with the word [ __ ] on that let
media please help us put this to sleep
you know you don't have this is gonna
sound like this is gonna sound so
arrogant but I've started saying this
because I'm so sick of it I started
telling people I'm like yeah everybody
fix if they put [ __ ] on the cover it's
gonna be a best-seller what they're
missing is that you have to put mark
Manson on the
Wow there might have to be some words in
between the cover and the back page
yeah make sense yeah I mean it's I I was
pretty diplomatic about it but at this
point there's like 12 or 15 other books
that are it must you must laugh when you
watch her a bookstore a bookstore or at
an airport and you see books that look
just like yours it's it's yeah I mean
you have to write how did that go down
when you tell the publisher like I'm not
gonna you know just do like it's not
gonna be Chicken Soup for the Soul you
know with 5,000 versions of the same
book I mean they were fine with that but
it's it's interesting because like
there's kind of an irony in that in a
and I'm sure this is true with every
creative field like when you're the
unknown guy they're actually very casual
with you if they're like hey man if you
need another few months with that draft
like take your time you know we're here
to help
uh-huh oh thanks guys I really
appreciate that when your big bestseller
they're like what the [ __ ] where's the
next book right we got to make money we
got to keep the lights on like you know
no no we won't edit it it's okay we'll
put it out you know and so you actually
have to it becomes much more combative
because strangely the incentives of the
author and the incentives of the
publisher are no longer aligned the
publisher you know it's they're just
they just want to cash in as quickly as
possible because they've got you know
investors and calls with Wall Street and
stuff where as an author you're like
wait I need to protect my brand I need
to like make sure I'm still doing this
ten years from now and so the second
time around it was way more combative
and they were trying to push me into a
lot of different ideas that I didn't
really want to go into they were pushing
me on timeline they wanted to put this
thing out like six months before it came
out I had to fight for you know subtle
art went through I think four or five
rounds of revision initially they only
wanted to do one with the new book I had
to fight for like three more I mean I
basically had to sit on it I mean I
basically
guys were not putting this out until
it's good well you're the guy who allows
all these other authors to write books
because most books don't make money yeah
it's the you know it's the one in 20 or
one and what I don't know whatever the
ratio is but you are the guy who's
keeping the lights on yeah but you're
the bank of all you know element here so
yeah it doesn't surprise me that the
pressure would come I know it should you
you carry you shoulder the
responsibility for all the other authors
who got you know fairly decent advances
that they'll never earn out right and in
its I I've told my agent I'm like you
know you would think that they would
like work with me you know I'd like to
make sure this is good if we want to you
know try to catch lightning in a bottle
like because it's like guys I want to
put up put out a follow up soon to like
you know it's good for me too but like
you know let's get on the same page here
so it was disheartening it makes you
realize or you know think that it really
is just about marketing and branding and
not about quality of content and it's I
think one thing that helped me a lot you
know so initially like the first six
months or so I I was constantly pissed
at them and eventually what helped me
understand is that you know you you
essentially you have this building full
of people who love books who make their
living selling books and they do pretty
much everything except to actually write
the book mm-hmm
and so anytime you have a group of
people whose livelihood is based on like
doing this one thing they'll start to
convince themselves that that one thing
is actually what moves and authors do
the same thing no yeah well my brilliant
work if the publisher didn't mess it up
like you know I would have sold five
times more copy you know so we're all
like they've got their biases I my
biases and so I think it's it's just
important to the communication just
needs to be good and sadly the industry
at least the publishing industry and
from what I've heard it's true in film
and music as well it's like the
communication is awful you know it's
it's very sneaky and kind of they do
things behind your back and try to like
they'll say one thing to your face but
you know meanwhile the marketing teams
doing stuff
completely different and it just feels
icky just feels really bad I mean I
haven't had you know crazy publishing
success my books have done well so I
can't you know I I don't have that kind
of direct experience but I do know that
there are a lot of myths you know that
people believe like when they write a
book that the publisher is gonna do
certain things
oh yeah it's not until you go through it
it's basically all on you yeah like you
really and it's like wait what are you
doing
again oh yeah you know you're printing
the book yeah I got that but you know
especially when it comes to the
marketing stuff and I heard you talking
to somebody where you even despite all
this crazy success you were still having
to kind of you know organize a lot of
your own yeah you know press the first
time around never did like mainstream
stuff so eight million books without
like you know spending five days in a
row on The Today Show or whatever yeah
yeah it's crazy and it's weird what's
weird too is that it's a distinctly
American thing so I've been on TV and
Brazil I've been on TV in Australia
because of the title I think so yeah and
I I think the other thing too I mean we
were talking about Ryan holiday before
we sat down but like I've talked to Ryan
about this a lot too is like I think the
the media in the US has this weird
prejudice against internet people so if
you built your platform online right
they pretend you don't exist until they
can't it's impossible for the right
pretend anymore and then once they stop
pretending it's this very condescending
like you know like oh well a lot of
people read him but we don't know why
right you know that that type of that's
very true and it's so interesting to
watch that I mean even if you like take
Joe Rogan for example oh yes the guy is
a behemoth it's a juggernaut you know
it's like if you're you know a young
male between 18 and you know I don't
know 36 or something like that he he
just might be the most important person
in you know media figures totally life
and and he's getting just millions and
millions and millions of downloads and
views on every single show that he does
and he
do you know four or five shows a week
yeah widely almost completely ignored by
mainstream media unless there's some
controversy that forces them to grapple
with him yeah but it's such an
interesting phenomenon that there's two
worlds that are existing that you know
the the mainstream media just you know
refuses to recognize this growing
reality and it's what's bizarre too is
that it's I mean it makes sense I guess
but I forget what article was but like
the New York Times mentioned him in an
article recently and it'd be like
totally brushed him off they're like oh
yeah this this fringe youtuber Joe Rogan
that people some people listen to his
audience is larger than like hits on
network television yeah telling my wife
I'm like I if you gave me the option of
like doing Joe Joe show or doing like
six having six profiles in the New York
Times over the next month yeah I would
do it doesn't even compare yeah it's not
even close yeah and I think that's why
they have that like they don't they
don't get it they're like like we're the
New York Times why don't people take us
as seriously as this guy on YouTube and
it's like well you know maybe you should
try to understand yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see how that unfolds over
the next couple years because it's
changing but it's interesting that you
would think it would be changing more
quickly yeah and again what's weird to
me is I don't get this sense in Canada
and Australia when I go to Canada I'm
going Australia tonight actually and
it's I mean I'm loaded all the morning
TV shows I'm doing all the biggest
newspapers like they do glowing profiles
and the interviews are good like it's
not it's not this but two men at two
second that's not this [ __ ] like
soundbite thing where you know once it
gets published you don't even recognize
half the stuff they quote you on it's
it's like they grapple with the the
philosophical content of my work and
they take it seriously yeah and so yeah
I don't know what it is
all right so 32 you're having this
existential crisis you know pre you know
pre
life crisis quarter life crisis or
whatever it is
and hindsight's 20/20 but looking
through the rearview mirror like your
second book is baked into this
experience so like all you have to do is
read your first book and go on this
search for you know what are your values
know and the path forward becomes
crystal clear like I did it I mean how
long did it take for that to dawn on you
that this needs to be the next book that
you're gonna write it was it was an
awkward experience because there were a
lot of so I so I signed on to do to do
more books with Harper and and I was
just under this immense both pressure
from them but also pressure for myself
of just like God how do I live up
through this thing how do I follow this
up all the stuff you said about
comparisons of like you know oh my god
that I peak at 32 like that sucks
and so I had a lot of kind of
therapeutic conversations with friends
and and family and they just look at me
they're like dude stop giving a [ __ ] you
know like take your own medicine take
your own advice and I'm like ah guys is
so embarrassing
well it speaks to how hard it is to
actually implement it is dumb you know
there's there's the intellect and you
talk about this in the new book the
difference between the thinking and the
feeling brain like sure intellectually
yeah I can I can crack that like I know
what you're talking about but then
actually practicing it moment to moment
to moment as you're experiencing
feelings that you've never encountered
before that's a whole different ball of
wax yeah yeah it's and it's in it's
intense because it is you know the I
guess the experiences I was going
through it at that time were so extreme
in so vastly different than anything I'd
ever encountered before but it's funny
eventually like what I came back to I
mean it sounds cliche but I had to
remember like why I write and I've
always written writing has always been
my own little kind of public form of
therapy and everything I write it's
because it's stuff that I'm dealing with
myself and by writing about it it helps
me kind of process and
understand my own values in worldview
and so it's I had a few book ideas that
I started on and I'm like like oh this
will be a huge hit or the publisher be
like hey maybe you should do that I'm
like alright I'll try to do that and it
just wasn't going anywhere and and I was
becoming more aware of all this stuff
that we're talking about around the same
time and I'm like what am i doing like I
need to go back to what I've always done
which is just take whatever I'm freaking
out about it at this moment and write it
out was there a sense though like uh was
there an impediment to that because you
felt like this is such a privileged
problem aren't gonna be able to relate
to it or is it just getting behind like
if you go past that and just get to the
truth of it which is the struggle for
identity you know essentially yeah that
we can all relate to well I so there's
everything we've been talking about is
kind of one thread there's a second
thread that went into this book which is
around the same time a lot of people a
lot of academics were publishing books
about like Steven Pinker's books and
Jonathan writes books they're publishing
all these books about how basically from
every material metric like the world is
great right now like it's were safer and
healthier and there's less conflict and
violence and crime than ever in world
history meanwhile you see all these
mental health issues escalating right
and so I was doing I was just out of
curiosity I was reading a lot of those
books and thinking into a lot of that
research and at some point I kind of put
two and two together like there's
something about this you know one of my
favorite quotes I think it's actually in
subtle art is that it's like if you if
you remove if you remove all all
problems from your life that your mind
will immediately set out to find new
ones I think it was a Jose Marti or
somebody said that but it's I always
like that quote I was like that always
kind of made sense but I you know all
these things kind of came together I'm
like wow there's something
about too much comfort or satisfaction
that seems to make us anxious and yeah a
little bit like our perceptions of
reality gets skewed a little bit and
then you take from that like everything
you know are basically our whole world
is built around our whole economy is
built around providing comfort and
convenience and satisfaction to people
and so I got on this kind of interesting
kick of like you know maybe the issue is
success maybe the issue is hope like
maybe it's too many of our dreams have
come true I mean and that's not to
downplay like the legit issues that are
going on today it's just to say that you
know when you're sitting in a nice
air-conditioned room with like 500
Netflix shows and you can have 20
different cuisines delivered to you from
like a press of a button suddenly all
these questions about identity and
purpose and you know what is what is the
meaning of my life and what what value
am i adding to the world like these all
they they actually become very difficult
questions
yeah we're much harder than say if
you're you know poor or you know living
out on a farm somewhere right you're
you're in in that case your mind is
occupied by meeting your needs it's so
yeah they become very pressing but when
those needs are met and you have clean
water and a roof over your head and you
have all the modern conveniences
yeah we've you know acclimated ourselves
to then what yeah and I think I think
we're also kind of reaching a saturation
point I think as a culture I know when I
was growing up there there was kind of
this unspoken cultural assumption of
like we need to fill our whole day with
stimulation whether it's entertainment
or learning something or like creating
value it's like every minute you're
awake there should be like some sort of
stimulation going on and I think in the
last five or 10 years we hit this point
of like stimulation saturation it's like
okay we were constantly stimulated
we are overflowing with stimulation in
and it's actually it complicates our it
complicates our understanding of
ourselves not it doesn't Claire clarify
it at all yeah our whole what you were
talking about what our economy is built
on I mean our economy is fundamentally
premise thanh marketing and advertising
and and you talked about this in the
book this shift in in advertising from
basically explaining why a product you
know what the what the benefits of
owning a product are to appealing to our
emotional bodies and trying to trigger
our fears and our insecurities and when
your needs are met now we're you know
fast forward to an era where we're
bombarded with messages that that are
telling us our lives will be better if
we have this or you're not enough
because you don't have that yeah and it
creates this future tripping mindset
that that Allah that prevents us from
being present in the moment that
consistently forces us to you know spin
out over what our future might be or how
we compare to our fellow man and
ultimately is this colossal distraction
there on what is truly important in life
yeah and it's I think I originally had a
whole chapter on this I kind of regret I
mean so this is one of the things that
like kind of rushing the book out I
think may be harmed it a little bit but
there's a section I think I have maybe
like three or four pages about it
towards the end of the book about
loneliness kind of the rise in
loneliness and loss of community I
originally had a whole chapter but the
chapter kind of sucked and instead of
having time like hash it out and fix it
I just took like the three or four pages
that were good and crammed it into the
chapter before and but it's funny
because the the you know I've been doing
this this speaking tour around the US
and Canada the last couple months and
I'm meeting a lot of people in person
and answering their questions and the
more time I'm like talking about all
these issues the more convinced I am
that the
the loneliness issue is maybe the
paramount one because I think what what
we don't realize is that the more
options and stimulation that we have in
front of us the less willing we are to
compromise what we want to like be with
somebody else you know so it's like if I
want to watch Netflix and you want to
like go to a concert it's like well [ __ ]
you i'm gonna watch netflix you know
like you know where's or if you you want
to watch two different shows you can sit
in the same room and both watch this
thing if i want to check my email and
you want to watch a show you know even
when you're with other people when your
face is planted into a screen you're
still alone yeah exactly and i mentioned
you know there's a there's a famous book
that came out about fifteen years ago
called Bowling Alone and and I talked
about it a little bit in the new book
but it's what he taught you basically
the it's called Bowling Alone because
more people than ever before are bowling
but there are fewer bowling leagues than
I've ever been and he kind of goes he
goes all the way across Society and you
know everything from like PTA groups to
church groups to political activism like
it's just fewer people are coming
together into into groups and
communities everybody's trying to do
everything themselves and he blames
entertainment he says that it's you know
the more options there are to be
entertained the more custom we become to
just I guess feeling entitled to do what
we want yeah and not be impeded upon by
other people but that causes
relationships to break down and so I
think we've got a bunch of lonely people
who aren't getting that face-to-face
exposure to to the world who are don't
feel like they're part of a community or
have significant relationships in their
lives yet they're constantly being
engaged through social media and just
the conventional media about like
political issues group issues social
identity issues and it's so easy for
them to respond you know so it's I think
the combination of those two things you
see this outrage
culture that's emerged where everybody's
just pissed off and feels victimized all
the time yeah and the more you engage
with that the more calcified you become
in your belief systems the more
resistant you are to being open to other
ideas yes and the more difficult it
becomes to actually change or be
open-minded about another way to think
and live yeah totally so how does this
Dove kit you have this this
counterintuitive arguably paradoxical
ideas around hope yeah so how does all
this like dovetail into this into the
into you know into into this thesis that
you've come up with about how we think
about and practice hope so I make the
argument that hope is Nessa stumped or
my hope we all need to believe that the
future can be better than it is today
that that's what gives us a sense of
meaning and purpose in our lives my
argument is that our visions of hope can
potentially be destructive because every
everything that you hope for you it's
it's by definition you hope for it on
faith like you you never know you know
it's like I had I believed on faith that
having a best-selling book would make my
life better I didn't actually know that
uh-huh it's just something I chose to
believe in it and it motivated me for
many years so we we all develop these
kind of faith-based belief systems
around what we hope for in the future it
could be religious it could be
non-religious and my argument is that
because these belief systems that we tie
so much of our mean personal meaning
into our at the end of the day kind of
arbitrary like we we need to defend them
against people we need to we protect our
hope and if people try to contradict
what we hope for you know they're the
enemy and we attack them and and so
there's this this kind of like shadow to
hope that never gets discussed
this destructive potential of hope and
so essentially I mean the book is really
just a very very careful what you hope
for and be I make the argument that as
our society and technology and
everything accelerates our ability to
fulfill our hopes that might not
necessarily be a good thing because it's
the having hope that sustains us when we
achieve what we hope for we we actually
lose our hope mm-hmm which is what
happened to me right and so in a very
paradoxical way it's giving people and
when I say giving people what they want
what I mean is kind of like I mean then
I'm more of a superficial level like
fulfilling people's desires can actually
kind of a road away at our at our
ability to feel so we have meaningful
lives mm-hmm it depends in some respect
though like how good your life is yeah
right like if you're like you use the
example of this guy will told Palicki
the the Polish dude who's like in you
know basically submits himself to
Auschwitz
life is just you know an endless stream
of like Horrors and and you know hope is
what sustains this guy but to use your
example when we're all in
air-conditioned homes and our needs are
met and we can postmates so everything
and we're on net we're watching Netflix
hope then gets kind of tweaked into you
know I would almost characterize it as
it gets it gets run through this you
know machine that turns it into fear
like fear of losing what we have
yeah and and an insecurity about how we
measure up to other people totally yeah
it's one of the paradoxical things they
talk about is that the worse things are
the easier it is to hope for something
and the more value that hope holds
exactly you know so it's like if war
breaks out and you know god forbid this
is like west coast is being bombed it's
like you and I suddenly know exactly
what we're waking up in the morning
but it's like when everything's just
[ __ ] great
we're just chillin drinking some tea
like looking at the mountain you know
it's like what do I hope for you know
there's whole seminars and there's a
billion dollar industry basically like
helping people figure out what the hell
they should hope for and like that is a
very privileged position that's actually
that's a criticism that the book has
received they're like oh this is just
hashtag first world brought and I'm like
yeah that's the point
like the point is that you know first
world creates a lot of you know people
get upset over a lot of like trifling
problems yeah and like that itself is a
problem yeah you know how do we become
aware of that in ourselves and manage
that in ourselves and not like do
something stupid mm-hmm the easy sell
from a marketing perspective is to
convince people that their lives are
gonna be better if they have a bunch of
money and they can sit on the couch and
go on these vacations yeah you know make
all of these choices and you know that
triggers something instinctually in all
of us that looks very good
yeah it's a much harder sell to tell
people listen you know forget about all
the life hacks yeah forget about the air
conditioning you'll actually be a much
happier person if you're forced to
confront yourself to grapple with your
you know character defects you're
compelled to put yourself in
uncomfortable situations and you know
expand the the the outer edges of your
comfort zone and to like [ __ ] do hard
[ __ ] yes absolutely
well don't want to hear that even though
time and time again you know especially
in the podcast world like people are
constantly talking about the value of
this and how this is really the path to
finding purpose and meaning and
ultimately fulfillment in your life yeah
yeah the the argument I make towards the
end of the book is that you know the
same way our body needs a certain amount
of stress and hardship distance to grow
to get stronger get more resilient I
think our minds need the same thing we
need mental challenges
you know it's like if you feel like you
know if you feel like I told my wife I'm
like you know it's at some point in the
next year I want to go like stay in a
roach infested hostel somewhere like I
like I did 10 years ago you know just so
that I don't
you're such an elitist I don't lose
myself you know because it's I'm not now
that I have money I'm enjoying luxury
but it's it's it's a trap you know like
it's it's because your mind adjusts and
suddenly you get to this point where
you're like well this is [ __ ] these
aren't feather pillows like you know you
know you call the front desk you're like
I demand this type of pillow and you
know it's like you don't want to be that
guy so it I think there's you know the
same way we need to challenge ourselves
physically I think we need to challenge
ourselves intellectually I think we need
to challenge ourselves emotionally and I
guess you could argue even challenge
ourselves spiritually well with success
the difference becomes that you have to
invite those challenges into your life
yes in a proactive way versus just you
know swatting them away like flies when
you're you know in the [ __ ] and just
trying to figure your life out totally
well in and this is why I actually think
the fitness analogy is perfect for this
because it's like if you're if you're
working on a ranch somewhere and
somebody's like hey man what's your
workout routine like they're gonna look
at you like you're crazy yeah working on
a ranch you're probably not the guy
who's gonna go sign up for the Spartan
Race yes you don't need that in your
life that's not a missing from your
daily experience exactly and so is it's
you know the people who sign up for the
Spartan Race are a bunch of like people
who are working in cubicles who are too
sedentary and not and aren't stressing
their physical and they're educated and
comfortable and yeah and it's it's so
they have to go seek that out and I
think we're gonna have to develop some
sort of regimen for ourselves of doing
the same thing intellectually and
emotionally yeah well no one gets out of
life alive right you know we're all
gonna die here and you know I believe
that the universe puts in front of you
what it is that you need to see and work
on the most so with your success it was
you know an argument could be made that
you were
you were you were you were this mirror
came up in front of you
you were forced to grapple with this
existential crisis and probably some
character defects that you really had to
look at that maybe if you're just in
survival mode and you're a blogger like
that's not pertinent yeah but when these
other problems get resolved you get new
problems and this is something you talk
about all the time it's like life is not
about getting rid of your problems yeah
it's like trying to get better problems
exactly exactly and in it again I do eat
my own what's that saying that you eat
your own shower eat your own [ __ ] boy
you could say [ __ ] yeah but yeah I mean
it's you're absolutely right and in its
what I think one of the things that was
very uncomfortable about the success of
the first book is that it did show me
that my values weren't so aligns as well
as I thought they were and that I
probably did put too much emphasis on
say commercial success or popularity and
that that that was what ended up you
know once I got it that's kind of what
messed me up you couldn't be told that
that wasn't gonna fill that hole you had
to experience that for yourself in order
to really connect with it yeah and I I
think honestly in my mind if you told me
back then that I cared too much about
I'd be like no I don't really care about
no right I'm fine
you know but it's do you experience it
you're like polishing your mentions on
Twitter yeah then you're like oh I'm
full of [ __ ] otherwise I wouldn't be
like this right now so let's talk about
the the fallacy of the pursuit of
happiness
sure elaborate your turn to talk you
know I I the argument I've always made
is that happiness is a byproduct of
working on the right things
choosing the good struggles mm-hmm
the problem with happiness is that it's
kind of like a mirage the more you run
towards it the further away it gets from
you and it's the fact that you're
running towards it
that makes that pushes it further away
from you it sound like trying to
meditate yeah right the more you try the
further away you are from actually doing
the thing exactly and and so it's just I
think I think there's also I didn't talk
about this in the book but I mean it's
if you look at you know and when
Aristotle defined two forms of happiness
there's kind of like a pleasurable
hedonistic happiness and then there's a
more like meaningful fulfillment
happiness and so the pleasurable
happiness is like sweet I've got like a
nice fruity drink and it's a beautiful
day and I want to go surfing or whatever
and you you basically it's just being
able to indulge on your desires whereas
the the more the fulfillment the more
meaningful happiness is about it's about
purpose it's about you know okay today
sucks not feeling good but I'm on the
path I want to be on and I think our
culture has lost that sense of like if
you look at what happiness meant
hundreds of years ago it usually meant
that fulfillment thing you know when
Thomas Jefferson wrote the right to
pursue happiness like it's basically the
right to pursue your life purpose what
that's gotten I think through consumer
culture and marketing and advertising
what that has been distorted into is you
have a right to feel good happy yeah you
have a right to have your desires
indulged and and we don't we don't and
it's funny I forget who well even if I
remembered I wouldn't call him out but I
didn't I did a podcast interview a
couple months ago and whoever it was was
like it's like yeah but don't we all
deserve to be happy I'm like [ __ ] you
why do you deserve to be happy who says
you deserve to be happy like it doesn't
you don't deserve anything you know like
if you want to feel something if you
want to have some experience like you
got to go out and get it you got to like
do you you gotta like find some sort of
meaningful struggle that that earns it
for you you can't just sit
be like I deserve be happy woohoo you
know so anyway that's my rant I got kind
of all over the place but no how's that
mesh with with the fact that Will Smith
has a movie called the pursuit of
happiness you know we talked about that
with him you know it's funny though you
know it's so funny so a few people
brought that up
and so we're you know working on this
bra and watched all these movies and
it's funny like that when that movie
came out I thought it was just kind of a
conventional movie about like a success
story like a homeless guy down on his
luck who like got this great job and
turned things around what's fascinating
if you go back and like really pay
attention to it the movie holds up it
really hold I think it's his best movie
he thinks it's his best movie it it's
there's some dark stuff that's happening
on the periphery of that movie like the
the homeless shelters the like churches
turning people away like it's it's
actually a very deep commentary on the
American Dream and he told me a really
interesting story it's gonna be in the
book he said that um when they were
trying to figure out who who did who
they wanted to direct the movie will I
forget the name of the he's an Italian
guy but will had seen this Italian movie
by this Italian guy really liked it it
was like hey let's talk to this Italian
guy and so the Italian guy comes out
comes California like doesn't even speak
English and is he's like stumbling his
way through like some awful pitch and
wills team is just like they're shaking
there they're like the others there's no
way and wills like kind of skeptical and
he said that the director could tell it
wasn't going well and finally he said he
said like what will can I say one thing
he said whatever you do he's like I can
kind of tell I'm not gonna get the job
but like whatever you do don't let an
American direct this movie and was like
why is that
and he said
because you can't Americans can't see
what the American dream actually is like
the naivet or no it's a de Tocqueville
kind of total right and so when you
watch it it is is actually a very
nuanced commentary on what what what
rags-to-riches actually is and what it
is what kind of society like we've
constructed that creates narratives like
like that and for every person like
Chris Gardner there's like 200 sitting
sitting in the hopeless shelter you know
probably today so it's like it's a
that's a bit of a tangent but it's
really like everybody should go back and
watch yeah I'm gonna go back and watch
it so he got the gig though oh it
totally like as soon as he said that
Will's like alright you got it alright
so in terms of like turning our
attention to decision making like how
can we you know make better decisions
about you know how we're moving forward
and how we're evaluating our values etc
you go into this deep dive on the
difference between the thinking mind and
the feet you know the thinking brain and
the feeling brain and the illusion that
we think we're all making logical
choices when in fact were just you know
we're just at the behest of emotional
you know light storm going on but you
get our ears yeah it's there's an
interesting history of kind of
understanding this aspect of ourselves
so to just summarize it really quickly
I used I've in a stent an extended
metaphor in the book of you have a
thinking brain in a feeling brain and if
your consciousness is a car most people
assume that it's our thinking brain
that's driving and our feeling brain is
kind of like this loud obnoxious kid and
the passenger seat that you're like shut
up shut up it's like always yelling at
you you know wants to go get candy and
wants to do whatever but the truth is if
you if you dive into the research like
the truth is that actually the feeling
brain is driving and the thinking brain
is the navigator the thinking brains the
one I saw in that apps and so there's
two ways that can go
the first way is that and I compared the
feeling brain to like like a like an
abusive bullheaded boyfriend or husband
like refuses to ask for directions
refuses to like change their you know
whatever so it's like there's two ways
this can go you're thinking brain can
either draw the maps that the feeling
brain wants to see to justify where the
feeling brain wants to go or you can
draw the maps in such a way to kind of
negotiate with the feeling brain of like
no this is the best way to go the first
way is kind of our default state you
know we all if we're tired if we're not
so we have looked like very low self
awareness if we're not very educated we
tend to just draw the map that are
feeling brain wants to see it takes a
lot of conscious effort take some
willpower takes a little bit you know
developing a skill of self-awareness to
be able to consistently draw the map
that kind of negotiate with our feeling
brain to get it to drive in the right
direction so because of this I make the
argument that all these questions about
you know habits and self-discipline and
willpower and procrastination all these
saying all these things that you know
there's a million productivity blogs
that have all these systems and all the
[ __ ] I'm like these are emotional
problems like if you yes if you can't
get yourself to work out consistently
that is not it's not your plan it's not
you know that you don't have the right
workout it's not that you don't have
like the right trainer it's it's an
emotional problem there's some you don't
go because it doesn't feel good and so
the real question is is how do you how
do you convince yourself how do you find
a way to make working out feel good how
do you find a way to to make eating
healthy feel good how do you find a way
to make being honest feel good like
these these are all fundamentally
emotionally based questions and so we
have to find emotional answers which
sucks because emotional answers are
hard in their individual you know
there's no book out there that's gonna
be able like you know here's how to and
there's they're salty people that like
in that context of self well and
discipline and people that struggle to
like wake up at a certain time or go to
the gym like certain people are more you
know short-term reward focused and other
people value you know the the long-term
payoff of like a certain kind of
practice yeah and I think you know
there's differences in how people are
wired fundamentally but I think it is
true like if you look at Chaco willing
who's like posting a photo every day if
I'm waking up at 4:30 right and and a
lot of people like it's inspiring yeah
but it's also shame provoking and a lot
of people that just can't get there or
maybe do it once or twice and then fall
off the bandwagon and never be like
Jocko
but that's doing something for Jocko
that aligns with his core values that's
the kind of person that he wants to be
and that may that may not be you like I
could I'm a very disciplined person yeah
I wanted to wake up at 4:30 every day I
could I did it all through high school
but I value mice you know I wanted hours
of sleep and I'm actually more
productive and I'm a better human being
when I get that so that's a value that
exceeds the value of getting up and
taking a picture of my watch every
morning to share on social sure yeah and
that works for me but I think the
challenge for people is to find it find
it first of all yes you have to grapple
with your emotional demons and figure
out what makes you tick and what what
you need to redress in order for you to
basically align your thinking brain your
thinking mind and you're feeling brain
in a way that they're you know sort of
charging you know down the superhighway
and unison with each other yeah yeah
it's I actually I used Jaco as an
example in the book because the 4:30
thing is perfect I think he said in his
book that the reason he started doing it
he did it in Iraq said made him feel
like he was getting an advantage over
his enemy it's serving something that
that works for him and yeah makes him
feel good
exactly and that narrative he brought
that narrative home and it still works
for him but I think you raised a really
good point
which
is and I don't think this gets discussed
enough I guess in the personal
development industry is is that it's
there's it's okay like if you try
Jacko's thing I mean I I would hate it I
already know like I I hate getting up
early and I used to beat myself up about
that you know it's like oh well you know
Beethoven got up at 5:00 a.m. I should
be a bit fight you know and it's like I
would try that and I'm like wow I just
feel awful like I don't like this and
eventually you have to arrive at a point
where it's like okay that's okay you
know you don't need to be like Jaco or
Tony Robbins or Bill Clinton or like
whoever whoever I need to feel bad about
yourself
yes you're not we're we're all wired
very individually but the caveat sorry I
don't share the caveat I would say is
chocos core principle of discipline
equals freedom still reigns true
absolutely got to find a different
discipline that gives you that sense of
freedom it may not be waking up at 4:30
in the morning but I truly I believe in
that edict and I absolutely - I mean you
talk about it in this books absolutely
yeah
yeah and it's it's I think it's
ultimately there's a central principle
of health and growth I think that needs
to drive everything you know some people
are early morning people some people are
not early-morning people you know our
circadian rhythms are different and our
brains kind of operate at different
hours differently and I think it's just
the ultimate principle should be just
understanding what works for you what
optimizes your time on this planet and
what what habits in disciplines as you
said you know can you implement that
that that optimize you essentially
mm-hmm that should be the question not
like oh [ __ ] well I didn't I guess I'm
just bad at this you know right because
I can't get up early so if you're
somebody who's feeling brain is going
haywire all the time and you struggle
with discipline and trying to adopt
practices that you know
you're thinking brain you know wants you
to adopt in order to be a more fulfilled
yeah person on a healthier trajectory
for yourself like what is the path
towards you know grappling with those
emotional barriers or whatever it is
inside of you that's preventing you from
making those changes
well the way I put it is that the
thinking brain the feeling brain need to
learn to speak to each other and the
problem is is that they speak different
languages and so people who tend to be
more thinking brain you know caught up
in their their thinking brain all the
time they're very bad at listening to
their emotions and so one aspect of that
conversation is you need to train
yourself to become more aware of your
emotions like what are you like when you
when you feel that resistance about
exercising or when you feel that like
deep urge to like either chocolate cake
or whatever it is you know ask yourself
like what are you feeling at that moment
it's that anxiety is it fear is it
desperation you know like really try to
pay attention to your body so that your
thinking brain can start deciphering
what you're feeling brain is telling it
and then it's got to go the other way
around too is that you have to if the
thinking brain kind of draws up a
potential new narrative or reality
you're feeling brain will try it on for
size you know so you you can enter into
the kind of this funny little
negotiation with yourself of like okay
going the gym feels really intimidating
right now you know what what if I just
go outside and walk for thirty minutes
instead like that's still exercise
that's still better than nothing you
know like and you listen you're feeling
brain you're like oh yeah that doesn't
feel so bad so you go outside and you
walk for 30 minutes and then at least
you get two feet you know you're feeling
brain gets that feeling of satisfaction
of accomplishment and the next time you
know you do that a few times and then
suddenly the gym doesn't feel so
intimidating you know and this plays out
for all sorts of different things I mean
essentially that conversation of
thinking brain and feeling brain trying
on new narrative seeing how it feels
that is what therapy is
so in other words to kind of break this
down your thinking brain says to you're
feeling brain all right dude
like I'm tired of being fat like getting
here here we're gonna go to the gym
everyday and the feeling brain has a
freakout yeah so they're not
communicating effectively that
negotiation you know quickly lead to an
impasse so all right let's step it down
yeah how can i how can i you know get
the feeling brain to do something that
is uncomfortable for the feeling brain
but not overwhelming that yes blowing
out all the circuits so you can like
stare step into it the other thing that
happens a lot too is that so people and
this happens on January 1st every year
people like alright this is it this is
the year I'm gonna do it you know and
then they wake up that first day and
they are pumped they're so excited and
then by day 4 you know they're like oh
god this again uh-huh yeah I'm not so
sure about this you know so they lose
that enthusiasm and and and that the
reason they stopped going is because
they lose that enthusiasm so the good
that the goal of the thinking brain is
to find ways to keep that enthusiasm
going you know the reason accountability
works the reason like going with a
friend works hiring a trainer it's
because the social pressure basically
pushes your feeling brain into enjoying
it you know it's like maybe I don't
enjoy going my moment by myself but my
best friend's gonna come with me and
that's gonna be fun
so yeah let's do it together it's so
annoying though that we can't like we
know we're gonna be happier once we're
we've lost that 30 pounds or we cross
the finish line at that marathon and yet
we can't it it's it's really inadequate
to try to leverage that in order to get
us to do the thing we need to do today
yeah work us ourselves towards that it's
too abstract you know you you're
thinking or you're feeling brain doesn't
understand past or future mm-hmm that's
why trauma still [ __ ] with us you know
it's like something happened 20 years
ago my feeling brain doesn't understand
that that was 20 years ago my feeling
brain still hurts now and it's the same
thing with the future you know you can
list 80 different reasons why adopting a
certain habit it's gonna benefit you you
know at the end you know it's you you're
gonna live longer you're gonna have more
money like whatever feeling brain
doesn't understand that feeling brain
understands now right which is gonna
lead us into this terrain of talking
about the present moment but before we
do that sure how does this feeling brain
thinking brain you know battle this
ongoing thing dovetail into these three
laws of emotion Oh men I kind of went
crazy with this with it with the emotion
thing you know I've always wanted to
write a book I've always wanted to like
really just lay out kind of the the
chain links between our experiences how
experiences lead to emotions how
emotions lead to our values and then how
our values lead to our identities or our
sense of like who we are and so chow the
first few chapters of the book are my
attempt to do that so the laws of
emotion are it's kind of it's a fun play
on Newton's laws of motion
you know first one is every every action
has an equal and opposite emotional
reaction secondly Messi's up I can worth
is this sum of our emotions over time
yep yeah third one is your identity
stays your identity until a new
experience acts against it yeah so
basically are our values are ultimately
derived from our emotional experiences
something super simple it's like if
growing up your dad always took you to
the baseball game you're light and you
in it was like the highlight of your
childhood you're likely going to value
baseball throughout most of your life
that's true of all of our experiences
everything that we find important in our
lives it is made us feel good at some
point in the past and generally the the
extent that we value it is
poor tional - how good it may made us
feel or I think a probably more accurate
way of putting this is the extent that
it met our needs so kind of like with
the the visions of hope it's like once
we find something in our life that we
find valuable we think is important we
hold on to that we protect it you know
it's like I am a baseball fan I go to
games I am like my dad and I did this
blah blah blah this is who I write this
is though this is the story that you're
telling yourself and other people yeah
exactly it's the story you're telling
yourself in it's the story you're
sharing with the world and it's how you
understand yourself now let's say that
you know you find out that your favorite
baseball team was you know crooked and
run by the Mafia and they are like not
there every all the games were rigged
and it just crushes you like absolutely
crushes you so that experience that
contrary experience to what you value
you know you love baseball and then you
find out it's all a lie like that your
devastation is proportional to how much
you value and so that that kind of
identity crisis that occurs when it's
like well I thought I love this thing
but it it screwed me over and now I
don't know who I am anymore the pain of
that fall is proportional to how high
you held it up right hostile and so
eventually you have to find something
else that you value to replace that to
to to keep to keep your identity some
sort of cohesive identity going and so
it's it's very much the same way that
you know physical objects move through
the world in very predictable ways I
think emotionally our understanding of
ourselves moves through the world in a
very predictable way and so it's useful
to understand how that happens but I
also think it's very useful to
understand that how arbitrary that is
that you know my love for baseball if I
had been born in France would have been
a love for soccer or if I had been born
with different genetics it would have
been I would have a different cultural
affinity or ethnic affinity so all these
things in our lives that we see is like
this is Who I am
they are ultimately a product of our
experiences and which are then a product
largely a product of the environment
that yeah and I think it's interesting
how we're selective about those
experiences there's something in our in
our unconscious mind that identify
certain things probably because of their
emotional valence that then become the
cornerstones in that story yeah where
when you really deconstruct it like it's
an illusion because it's a continuum of
billions of experiences that we've had
and for some reason there's certain ones
that pop up that that we then craft this
whole sense of who we are around yeah
and I think just looking at that and
being honest with ourselves about that
helps us deconstruct that but I'm
interested in in this model which I you
know I agree with you completely but how
does this model hold up in our post fact
fake news world where you know when
we're told our baseball team was just a
bunch of crooks yeah and there's all
these newspaper articles about it we
instead of allowing that to seep in and
and forcing us to find new identity we
just refute it and dig in even deeper
yeah and I think that this is is what
we're seeing this is endemic to our
culture right now across the board
absolutely and it's freezing us in this
space that is moving us away and you get
into this in the later part of the book
moving us away from all of the freedom
that we you know
you know aspire to have in our life and
that we espouse in our you know in in in
the way that we live yeah I think it's a
couple things I think one thing is that
right now our media or our not not just
media but like the way information
travels in our society is very much
based on attention so
it's it's it's the the most factual
thing is not what travels the furthest
in fact studies are showing that it's
actually the the bigger the lie the more
trials that what's that adage like a lie
goes around the world yeah a hundred
thousand times before the truth can get
out of the gate or whatever yeah
something like that yeah
and yeah so the in terms of virality and
everything like that the research is
bearing that out so the problem is is
that everything is based on attention
everything is based on if I can get
enough clicks then I can make bunch of
money and whatever the problem with that
is that let's say let's say that I so
keep keep this ridiculous baseball
analogy going let's say that I'm like a
intrepid reporter who spent six months
of my life digging into this huge
baseball scandal and it's gonna bring
the sport to its knees are you gonna
pick a team here yeah yeah well let's
say the Yankees oh you know it's like I
I'm investigating the Yankees I find
just corruption at every level you know
and the players are throwing the games
and you know the refs are in on it and
yada yada yada and uh and I published
this huge like forty page investigating
right he's like a Ronan Farrow yeah
Yorker exactly say exactly
it doesn't matter how right I am because
as soon as that gets published and gets
all the attention and all the clicks
it creates there it's such a big
incentive for anybody to come out and
contradict me because they're gonna
siphon off like half of those clicks so
this is why like anything you see at my
talks I I use nutrition as an example
it's like if you if you like Google like
how do I lose weight you know you'll go
to one article and it's like oh you just
cut out fat and then it's like no no
that's a lie cut out carbs and it's like
no no carbs are good no no you got to
cut out meat and you know and it's like
everything is just trying to contradict
each other because the easiest way to
grab attention is to contradict whatever
currently has a
mention and so when you play this out
for years and years and years where it's
like everything that is is grabbing
attention gets immediately contradicted
by something else that you enter into
this this post truth reality where it's
like well just pick a side you know
whatever you and and when it comes down
to pick a side it's the feeling brain
just goes well it's like well becomes
all feeling yeah it's like I like
baseball so this this I love the Yankees
yeah I love the Yankees and so this guy
mark Manson's [ __ ] and it's all set
up and the media is just trying to
corrupt sports because they want to like
whatever or you know and it's because it
all appears the same when everything is
just contradiction right it's when it's
like when you're watching a new show and
there's ten people you know in those
little boxes and they're all shouting
and yeah the inference is that their
opinions are all of equal value yes yeah
and it's that that's that's a really
good example because that's been going
on for for decades now you know like
they'll bring on like a climate
scientist and they'll bring on some
fringe right wing loon who thinks it's
all a hoax and they'll put them
side-by-side and wait and let them
debate each other and it's and so if
you're a viewer you're like alright I'll
just pick a side you know because it's
it's in the structure of the media
environment is is that it's it's in
their favor to always keep things it's
like Vegas you always want to keep
things equal on both sides you know like
that's that's where the most money is
the problem is is when you're talking
about information and truth and you know
politics and things like that
it has a very corrosive effect on our
society
so let's telescope that out then from
the micro example of the Yankees or the
nez program to you know
governments and democracy and and how we
how we live essentially you know like
the structures that drive you know how
we live day to day yeah so we eat once
once everything becomes contradiction we
start losing faith in all these social
structures that we depend on
you know and one of the things I I
talked about early on the book is that
you know and this is this is something
that Harare popularized popularized with
sapiens but it's like all these social
structures are based on faith they are
based on like a democracy is a faith
based construct of like we all just
agree yeah
my corporation yeah all of these are
illusions that we've made a social
contract exactly exactly and so when you
start contradicting everything those
illusions start breaking down and so you
you get situations like today where you
know where it's like fundamental
branches of government that we all
depend on you know it's like all now
it's the deep state and they're trying
to like you know subvert everything or
on the left you know it's like every now
it's now you've got fascists in power
you know and so it's it's it's these
constant kind of extreme messages of
like oh we have to tear the whole thing
down and this this kind of comes full
circle back to my original point of like
things are great and everybody's
freaking out because it's none of the
problems that we have today and yes we
have a lot of problems but none of the
problems we have today are problems that
we haven't had in the past that we
haven't dealt with in the past and yet
the level of despair anxiety and
depression has never been higher right
in in in turn politically speaking you
have large groups on both the right and
the left who are ready to just tear
everything down say you know what let's
start over and it like that
that is the danger like that's the
bigger danger like what's going on and
they like Congress has been gridlocked
before you know we've had you know we've
had all sorts of corruption and
breakdowns in different parts of the
government before like the system is
designed to compensate and kind of hold
itself together the only thing that can
bring it down is when a critical mass of
people are like no it's all [ __ ]
right and that's being weaponized right
now yeah you know there are vested
interest who are very savvy and are
swaying public opinion by using the
levers of Technology
you tilt the scales and it that that
becomes something unprecedented yeah in
history and and rather terrifying yeah
yeah it's um it's a strange time it's a
very strange time meanwhile technology
continues to advance we're seeing
innovation at a rate that we've never
seen before yeah and this gets into a
you know a related subject that you talk
about in the book which is how these
innovations which we're all welcoming
into our lives and signing up for and
excited about and can't wait for the new
iteration of and yet they're all fueling
they're really just fueling diversion
that is reducing our the freedoms that
we think that you know we should we that
were enjoying and yeah and should be
increasing yeah it's um so this kind of
ties into the Jacko's thing about
freedom equals discipline or discipline
equals freedom it's one of the I guess
more profound conclusions and I say
profound for me I don't know if anybody
else cares but for me personally one of
the more profound conclusions I came to
the last four or five years is this
realization that like freedom isn't
necessarily having more stuff or more
options or being able to do more things
what real freedom is is the ability to
commit to choose my commitment to choose
the people I want to be with to choose
the information I want to engage with to
choose the work I want to spend my life
pursuing and it's I make the argument in
the book that this proliferation of
options that we're essentially we're
mistaking options for freedom and
options are great when you have no
options options are great they increase
freedom but once you have options if
once up the options get to the point
like way way way past the point that
you're ever gonna be able to choose from
them you're just continually scrolling
down Netflix and it just keeps going
yeah there's a joke on Saturday Night
Live like the goal is just by the time
you're done scrolling they've now added
new [ __ ]
it just becomes
perpetual Habitrail it feels like we're
getting there uh but absolutely you know
it's the classic like 500 channels on TV
is nothing on and it's it's the the
proliferation of options has
psychological effects on us it makes us
there's a thing called paradox of choice
which you know if you if you give people
an option between two two types of
cereal and you know you pick one and
you're like all right I got the better
cereal you're satisfied with it if you
give people not a choice between 20
types of cereal on paper that sounds
like a better deal but actually what
happens is is people first of all they
like get really anxious and an obsessive
are worried that they're gonna pick the
wrong one and then once they pick it
they're less satisfied with whatever
they picked because they're actually
thinking more about the 19 that they
gave on the pick you know and that
ultimately leads to that's you know the
root of FOMO I guess on some level and
it just makes people feel despairing
like they're always missing out yeah
they can't make the right choice it's
disorienting yeah yeah for sure
so let's get into this idea of finding
the solution in the present moment okay
yeah so hope is about the future yep
these stories we tell ourselves about
who we are are rooted in the past yes
these are things that are fueling you
know all of these conditions that we're
seeing the epidemic of loneliness and
depression and anxiety and all of this
it all goes back to the ancient wisdom
here in the now man yeah right this idea
yeah I came up with the present moment
um thank you it really is incredible you
know so I I my background you know
people who read some art by figuring
this out but like my background is like
a Buddhist background I see you've got
the the statue you got all the new-age
trapping
yeah but I was I got the amor fati oh
yes I can talk about a minute absolutely
I got yeah I'm going there actually so
my backgrounds a little bit a little bit
Buddhist I spent a lot of my college
years and 20s like engaging with it and
practicing meditation and really getting
into it and so it's funny I'm kind of I
got on this big Western philosophy kick
after subtle art came out and I had read
some stuff in college but some of it was
interesting and some of it was
completely indecipherable but I guess at
some point in the last 15 years my brain
is like developed the attention span and
patience to actually like wade through
mmm Conte and Ichi and so I was reading
a lot of Western philosophy and I was
really finding it inspiring in a lot of
ways and it's crazy because it's it all
just comes back to the same principles
and you know need Nietzsche I talked
about Nietzsche in the book Nietzsche
was he's considered the first post
modernist which is because he he
basically showed up and he was like look
any human system because it was
conceived of by humans is going to be
inherently flawed and faulty and it's
never gonna last anything anything you
can conceive of it's gonna fail at some
point and so ultimately the conclusion
that he arrived upon is you just need to
learn to love the failure he called it a
more fatty love your fame just
understand it everything's and what's
amazing too is that he was people in
Europe weren't aware of the Buddhist
stuff at this time and so you know
they're kind of arriving at this
independently in their own way and then
it's it's it's the same as saying stop
resisting what is yeah and embrace the
now absolutely in surrender and
acceptance yep absolutely
and and then caught it was a similar
thing
you know can't can't actually tried to
do what Nietzsche said was impossible
which is to find some sort of universal
moral principle of like okay this is the
one thing that we should all value above
all else and he really struggled with it
and he I think he only he came up with a
Colton categorical imperatives and I
think he only came up with three and
they've been torn to shreds ever since
by a lot of really smart people and two
of them in particular but that there is
a third one which I thought I think
holds up the best out of the three which
is what he called this formula of
humanity which essentially never treat
an individual a conscious individual as
a means always as an end which is kind
of a fancy philosophical way of saying
you know the highest value the thing we
should value more than anything else is
always the dignity of each human being
and if you subscribe to any sort of
religion or ideology or relationship or
passion that ever forces you to treat
another individual as a means does not
respect their inherent dignity as a
human being then that is a moral failure
yeah you described it as stop living a
transactional life yeah right to live a
transactional life is to treat another
individual or a situation as a means to
an end which immediately gets you into
the future they're plotting and planning
yes you're you know you're trying to
create a machination that's gonna get
you to this other place at some
unspecified future time as opposed to
living in the moment
treating somebody as an end in and of
itself which is another way of saying
just be present with who you are yes and
who that person is and be unconditional
in your actions you know treat
everything to that one get torn down
because that one holds up pretty well
I I have not seen any convincing
destruction of it
and it's it what's amazing too is that
it the same principle is really at the
heart of pretty much every major
religion I think it's just it's all the
institutional stuff you know so it's
like the teachings of Jesus or Mohammed
or Buddha like that it's all like you
know Buddha's like cause no suffering
Jesus is like love your neighbor you
know it's it's like it's all the same
stuff it's just all these cultural
institutions get built on top of it that
then start treating people as means to
ends but it's it's you know that that
transactional thing is that is where the
destructive side of hope emerges because
you get people who are like well
violence is wrong but I'm pretty sure
this guy's a Nazi so I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of them you know and it's like
that's where evil starts that's at least
that's what Kahn said that's where evil
starts because you are you the basis of
your actions is no longer the inherent
human dignity of each individual the
ends don't justify the means yes that if
if the means are other people never
right so to extend that into a thought
experiment if you could go back in time
and like murder Hitler when he was a
baby like how does that play out right
that's where it could stay but I
understand your point which is
essentially you know listen how other
people are living their lives really is
none of your business it's not for you
to take their inventory and be a B of G
in judgment of them let's cast that you
know turn that mirror around and look at
yourself sure focus on being the best
person that you can be and when you
enter into every situation if you can be
present and if you can try to identify
the shared divinity between you and that
other person and hold you know hold that
person in their highest regard and just
be in allowing yeah that that is
actually a much better plan for life
yeah I mean I I think I think as
individuals absolutely I think part part
of where it gets sticky is that the
nature of politics is very true
like I think we've kind of built a
transactional system just because we
understand how selfish and prejudiced
humans are like I think that that is
really the genius of democracy is that
people like Thomas Jefferson and James
Madison realized how shitty people are
in or like oh that's why we're a
democratic republic and yes you're a
democracy absolutely it's a you know a
stop on that yeah but it's it's um I
think what I love about that Kant's
principle because it you know I spin
basically a half the first half of the
book explaining like how all of our
hopes and values are created and then at
the very end I I have the nietzsche
chapter which just tears everything that
and so you you're actually left with
like a little bit of a bleak situation
and I get a lot of emails from people
who like to die just finish the first
part your book like this is the downer
man like I might keep going it's okay I
keep going you know and I think the
beauty of Kant's principle is that it's
it's the only thing I've really found
that doesn't you don't need an ideology
or a belief system or any sort of like
structure institutional structure to
practice it you don't need anything in
your environment to be correct you know
you don't need it it's it's true for
every individual it's true no matter
what situation you're in you know and
it's always it can always be practiced
in the present moment as you said like
it's no matter how much you [ __ ] people
over in the past no matter how much you
want to [ __ ] people over in the future
in this moment you can treat people
unconditionally as an ends and not just
a means the irony and that is that when
you do do that all the things that
you're kind of aspiring to manifest in
your life are actually more likely to
occur if you go into every situation in
a transactional mindset yeah like I'm
gonna you know like a you know I'm going
to this marketing conference so I'm
gonna meet all these people and they're
all gonna help me and make my career and
you're in there just you know trying to
get stuff from people nobody want nobody
you know
nobody likes that guy you know but if
you just show up full of heart yeah and
they remember like wow I really like
talking to that person yeah like how can
you know how can i I want that person in
my life yeah you're you're more likely
to create a social circle that's
conducive to to the things that you're
trying to do which which and it's funny
I just now put this together but that's
what that explains the backwards law I
talked about in subtle art and you know
this this idea that the more you let go
the more you have yeah that's been so
true in my own life and I've seen it
operative and so many people oh
absolutely and it's so counterintuitive
it really is and it really it requires
you to live in faith well yeah because
you you have to just believe yeah I mean
you have to let go of all of that
conditioning and programming in order to
inhabit that space yep and and it's a
constant you have to constantly remind
yourself - because we're all default
back into those you know ways that we've
always behaved yeah all right so let's
Marshall in the robots yeah so talk
about like a counterintuitive way to
kind of close this book down to like
there's a lot of talk about AI you know
it you know we're afraid of a a Isaiah a
good thing we've got people like Elon
Musk and some very smart people out
there waving a very cautionary tale
about what this is going to usher in we
need to have these conversations about
what we're doing and have stops and
controls you take a very different tack
yeah I I again find myself
I think standing kind of alone here you
know so there's there's two camps but
they I there's I I think you call them
kind of the utopians which think that AI
is gonna create this amazing place where
humans can just chill out at the beach
for forever as we've just explored over
the last couple hours this is you're not
gonna get a have you transcend your you
know your your your feeling brain no
matter even if you're uploaded to the
cloud yeah so you've got those people
and then you've got I think kind of the
doomsayers like musk who are a concern
that we
who I think very rightly recognized that
as soon as we create something that is
some sort of super intelligent entity
that's outstrips all of our intelligence
we're gonna be out of control
and because it's good people outsmart us
manipulate us whatever I so I often
describe my work as pessimistic
self-help you know one thing I say a lot
when I do interviews or go on TV is you
know I say most self-help is very
idealistic about human nature you know
they believe we can do anything we can
if you believe it you can go do it if
you just need to think positive and all
this stuff I don't like any of that [ __ ]
I spent enough time with psych research
to understand that humans are we're
inherently flawed selfish somewhat
shitty creatures and we don't treat
ourselves well we don't treat other
people well so my work has always been
instead of like hey you can do anything
you want my work has always been let's
just try to be a little less shitty
let's let's be aware of how flawed we
are and work on those flaws so bringing
that back to the AAI thing I'm a
pessimist about human nature and so yes
I do think we're gonna lose control to
to AI but no I don't think that's a bad
thing I don't think they're gonna wipe
us out why that's like that's like being
like well you know horses aren't
productive anymore so we're gonna kill
all the horse like why you there's no
reason to do that you know so humans
gonna be fine we're just gonna be like
the horses and the AI Society you know
it's like oh you'll be fine
hey won't it be fun to get to get rich
to go do that thing right you know what
if we're not the horses were the ants
that - I mean what's wrong with that
well it just means that we're so we're
so insignificant to the AI that that our
well-being doesn't even factor into
whatever decision is being made
the future of the planet yeah and we
could be eradicated without a second
thought but that's dream we should be I
don't know but that's true already I
mean like we could be eradicated at any
moment you know asteroid dance or
whatever I just I don't see I don't see
the problem with it I and I think you
know given how I think it's far more
likely we're gonna blow ourselves up
than AI is well I think it's a it's a
timing thing right like it's gonna take
longer for AI to advance to the point
where it becomes sophisticated enough to
do that we're more likely to blow
ourselves up in the short term yeah in
the long term I think it were more
likely to fall prey to the whimsical or
maybe not the algorithmic all desires
artificial intelligence that we have
created yeah but it's and I mentioned
that so I finished the book with a kind
of a cheeky list of hopes that I have
and one of them is is that we don't blow
ourselves up before they I can develop
enough to like you know take the gun
away from the baby yeah to challenge you
a little bit the earth your whole thesis
here is that we've arrived at this place
in culture where our needs are met and
this is creating this existential crisis
and have these mental health disorders
but eight won't AI just exacerbate that
it's gonna fill all these other needs so
that we literally become like the guys
in the wheelchairs and wall-e I never
have said anything not in this I mean we
take dogs for walks you know it's like
why won't the why won't they I take us
for a walk like I talk I've got this
little a I could walk the dog but but
what I'm saying is like I'll have robot
dogs well I have this kind of like fun
sci-fi moment in the last chapter about
this where I say like yeah we'll all be
will be in like some virtual reality
cloud where the AI is constructed some
game that we're all engaged in that
keeps us occupied and that we're all we
all enjoy ultimate distraction yeah now
we become batteries like in the matrix
sure why not
sign me up yeah like the doodle what's
wrong with the matrix dad all right well
when that happens and then you have your
next existential crisis then you have
the material for the follow-up book
about wise I think that's a good James
all teacher called this book the Victor
Frankel's man's search for meaning for
for the next generation and I I see I
see why he said that I think there's a
lot there's a lot to that it's a bold
statement it's really bold but you have
sold a lot of busts so bold it makes me
uncomfortable
I guess we'll know if AI if the robots
don't kill us in a hundred years and we
can revisit this and see whether it
holds up but I love the books I love the
work that you're doing I think you're
doing you know some some deep thinking
about issues that are really important
and and and and affect all of us so keep
doing it my face thanks for coming by
preciate it
appreciate it glad to be your piece